[Applause]
what are you afraid of well I was gonna
go with flying but I think I'll go with
girls over 12 its lucky you're beautiful
because there's nothing up here that's
me did you just saw your dumb you went
straight to dumb like woman I was like
oh you're wearing my grandma's sweater
and then you're like your dumb fur lives
in Brighton he fits right in because if
there's one thing the residents of
Brighton love it's a hairy bum your
biceps look like Thanksgiving turkeys
Michelle do you know who any of us are
when I saw you I thought maybe you
Benedict Cumberbatch had gotten in a
terrible do you like the title celebrity
chef I'm not a separate chef no I'm a
man yes you are listen I am NOT gonna
start arguing the dwarf listens over
[Applause]
[ __ ] Suzy what have you been looking
into recently other than glory holes you
know give us to know you why you're
famous that would equate to celebrity so
I went is you're a [ __ ] for a living and
people that you are is why don't you
pull that like that we'll see because
you've got a long Norma's penis
[Applause]
it's like he's like a little gremlin how
much do you turn it off lieutenant I
don't listen have you got your high
heels on
how can punch like a girl but I can
still punch you scratch I did that yeah
you don't see me coming but I that I
missed the last category if you win you
know we'll win all right the Emmy for
the road that makes a lot of sense but
you must be really bummed out yeah I'm a
little disappointed
thank you so you're not you're not gonna
get a trophy no I don't get a trophy
then are you finished Don wait who did
get a trophy who won John Oliver is just
that what do you mean yes yes they know
I knew I had him in my pool
you mind if I continue with the show no
I mean I'm sorry but what am i doing
I'm see this is so humiliating let's say
can we cheer Jimmy up how about he's a
big loser and there's Charles Woodson
how about that oh what a season yeah
[Applause]
it became the first defensive player to
win the Heisman Trophy congratulations
Charles that is something that no one
can ever take away from you unless you
kill your wife and a waiter in which
case
[Applause]
secretary states here and Billy Graham
nice to see you sir
this hand is bothering me Chinese right
Chinese this girl here if you're not get
your eyes fixed the Chinese boat sitting
the girl who's Chinese host you are so
old that your publicist
is a registered nurse but now we're both
happily married so you went through a
couple of warmups but Anthony this is
your type no yeah she looks like a
cartoon of a [ __ ]
you took that well she takes a lot of
things well during our sex scene I felt
your dick rubbing engine is that it with
your blue eyes and your perfect hair and
your beautiful 3-piece suit get
fashionable expensive three-piece suit
you look amazing
John Cena John Sammy stop your fingers
on flap so wasting my time I'm at the
White House I'm not the White House
David Krumholtz his show is called
numbers Friday nights at 10:00 on CBS
sincere apologies to Matt Damon
we ran at a time for him tonight we'll
get him on the air again soon apologies
and Matt Damon we ran out of time Matt
Damon apologies we ran out of time Matt
Damon apologies ran out of time
apologies the Matt Damon ran at a time
apologies for Matt Damon we ran out of
time for Matt Damon I'm sorry we ran out
of time apologies the Matt Damon ran out
of titles apologies the Matt Damon he
had a baby today so it really was the
wrong thing to do to bump him but we had
to apologize to Matt
[Applause]
unfortunately we are totally out of time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]